This is Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vedanta. Seattle is a city with plenty of well-known tourist attractions. The space needle, Pike Place Market, the Seattle Art Museum. Today though, I'm venturing out in the rain to visit a different sort of Seattle attraction. It's an office building called the Bullet Center. I'm here to meet Brian Court, one of the architects. Hey Brian, Shankar. Shankar, nice to meet you.
Very nice to meet you. Thank you for doing this at short notice. Brian and I are headed to the top floor. My first instinct is to find the elevator. But it's nowhere in sight. Did you forget to put an elevator in the building, Brian? We do have an elevator through the door to the left. If you're in a wheelchair or you're not able to climb the building, Brian. We do have an elevator through the door to the left. If you're in a wheelchair
or you're not able to climb the stairs, you just hit the button there with the wheelchair and that door will open, but we were trying to give people an option to take the stair first. Those stairs, there are six floors of Douglas Four Steps built on an outer wall of the building. Each floor has expansive landings that allow people to congregate and chat. The best views at the Bullets Center are not from the CEO's office. You get those views when you climb what people here refer to as the irresistible staircase. So you walk into the stair enclosure, you look up, you see the stair all the way up to the sixth floor of the building, and that's hopefully going to draw you up the stair enclosure. You look up, you see the stair all the way up to the sixth floor of the building,
and that's hopefully going to draw you up the stair. The designers wanted to build a staircase that would help people become healthier. Their intuition was that if the stairs were appealing and prominent, people would use them. What you see as you climb to the sixth floor are sweeping views of Seattle. You'll notice as we get higher views of this city really start to unfold. This corner of the project site had some of the best views you can see out now to the west and then the downtown skyline directly to the south. By putting a stair here we're able to really capitalize on views all the way from the east around to the west.
So far Brian says this irresistible staircase seems to be living up to its name. We've actually got data that's showing us that just about two thirds of the people that go to the sixth floor on a daily basis are taken the stair over the elevator. Most buildings place the elevator's front and center as you walk inside. Most of us don't even think to look for the stairs when we enter an office building. By making the stairs prominent and keeping the elevators out of sight, the bullet center is trying to get people to develop new behaviors. Sometimes, unexpected things happen as you clam these stairs. You bump into
people, you didn't think you'd meet. That's Rashad Morris. He walked down a flight of stairs to come say hello. He told me he takes the stairs nearly every day and he often has chance interactions on them that turn out to be very enjoyable Do you actually think about it each day that you're saying I want to take the stairs Or is it just sort of an unconscious decision at this point? There are sometimes when I'm coming from downtown and I've walked all the way up Capitol Hill And I get to the door of the building and I think oh man another six flights But then I think you know I don't get a whole lot of exercise in my day-to-day work life anyway.
And so this is worth it. And I enjoy the view always. There's a word for such behaviors. There are habits. This week on Hidden Brain, we consider how habits shape who we are and how we can use them to become the people we'd like to be. You probably know someone like this in your life. The person who gets a ton of things done, eats healthy food and stays in shape. People like Chris Trigger from the TV series Parks and Recreation. Sorry, Wesley. Damn! I have to go run 10 miles. People like Chris Trigger from the TV series Parks and Recreation. Picture a guy who strips off his workloads to reveal a running outfit underneath.
Now, Chris Trigger is a fictional character exaggerated for comedic effect. But we all know someone like this, a friend or colleague or spouse who consistently performs the tasks that seem so hard to the rest of us. How do they do it? What do they have that the rest of us lack? According to Wendy Wood, a professor of psychology and business at the University of Southern California, characters like Chris Trigger are not magical unicorns. They just have a secret. They are expert at building good habits. In her book, Good Habits, Bad Habits, The Science of Making Positive Changes That Stick, Wendy argues that we can all become experts at building good habits and dismantling bad
ones. If we only stop to understand the psychology behind our routines. Wendy, welcome to Hidden Brain. Oh, I'm thrilled to be here. I want to start with something that you once saw on Facebook. Your cousin went on Facebook and announced that she was going to change her life by which she meant she wanted to lose some weight. Why did she announce this on Facebook?
And what was the reaction she garnered from her friends? So I think by making a public statement, she was trying to commit herself to the initial idea, her initial desire to lose weight. In a way, she sort of upped the stakes because she made it public, and then she was accountable to all of her Facebook friends, and they were highly supportive. They spurred her on and told her how strong she was. So she got a lot of positive reinforcement for that. And the feedback from her friends, this idea that in the idea of encouraging her or telling
her just do it, you know that reminds me of a video made by the actor, Shia LaBoff. He stands in front of a green screen and he says, actually, actually, let me just play for you what he says. Take a listen. Yesterday you said tomorrow, so just do it. Make your dreams come true. Just do it. This message is so pervasive when it comes to making changes in our life, the idea that if you want to make a change,
all you have to do is just say, just do it. Wouldn't that be wonderful? I don't think that's most of our experience. that if you want to make a change, all you have to do is just say, just do it. Wouldn't that be wonderful? I don't think that's most of our experience, but what we do believe is if we wanted to enough, we'd exert enough willpower and we'd make it happen. And the result, though, is that it doesn't often because willpower is not actually, we have found, the best way to achieve our goals and to change our behavior. Talk about this idea, Wendy, that significant numbers of Americans believe that the way to change their behavior is through self-control, that willpower is the key to either making changes that stake or to making changes that fail to stick. Yeah. It's something that pervades our culture.
When surveys are done of Americans and their beliefs about how to change behavior, particularly something like obesity, three quarters of Americans think that it's a problem with self-control and willpower that we just don't have enough. And if we had more, we'd all be thinner. Now researchers have actually looked at this question and asked how much willpower is central.
You cite the work of the late great psychologist, Daniel Wegner, who once ran a study where he told people not to think about a white bear. Why did he do that? And what did he find? He did it to show that if you try not to think about something, even something as trivial as a white bear that you wouldn't normally think about, then later when you're given an opportunity to think about it again, you just can't stop.
It's a white bear, white bear, white bear. So this tells us something about what it's like to try to repress or control our desires. Yes, we can do it in the short run, but ultimately, it backfires. Those ideas get a life of their own and they start to obsess us. And when you think about the behaviors we often want to change in our lives, quitting, smoking, or eating healthier, or exercising more regularly, the challenge of course is not to make a one-time change, not to exercise well just today, the challenge of course is to make a long-term change, and the research would then suggest that willpower might not be the most effective way to go about
achieving that. Yes, that's actually how I got into this whole research area. Yes, that's actually how I got into this whole research area. I was interested in understanding what it is that helps people persist. So how do people persist at say eating healthfully or saving more money or getting more sleep? We can all do this one time or two times, but it's a very different thing to do it on a consistent basis. When I first started this research, the idea was that we did these things when we were sufficiently committed, when we had enough self-control to follow through, then we'd form these strong intentions and we'd act on them over time. But I'd noticed that it didn't really play out that way in my life.
I've often made decisions that I didn't follow through with, even though I was initially very committed to those decisions, and I have a pretty good amount of willpower. So what we did is we did a large review of the research to test whether people's decision-making was important all the way through behavior change process, not just from the beginning, where my cousin started on Facebook declaring she's going to change, but also two, three months later. And what we found was really surprising. Decision making our intentions, our thoughts, our commitment, they're very important when
we start to change. That's what determines whether we do behaviors once in a while, continuing over time, took something very different. And we didn't know what it was to start off with. It was like once you start performing a behavior it just sort of continues on its own. It's like action begets action. And what we decided was this is kind of like driving your car, right? So every once in a while you do pay attention and make decisions but most of the time when you're driving it's sort of in the background. You're thinking about something other than what you're doing, your actual responses don't take much thought and decision.
They're certainly not taking your willpower. It's a counterintuitive idea. Conscious willpower is not the driving force behind sustained behavior change. That idea is powerfully illustrated by an experiment conducted in Germany that ask two simple questions. Are people who stick to their resolutions, the people who see lots of temptations, but have the willpower to resist them? Or are they the kind of people who have set up their lives so they don't even notice the temptations.
They found that contrary to all of our expectations, that people who are high achievers, who we think of as having good willpower, good self-control, they didn't actually experience many temptations. They weren't conflicted by having lots of desires that were inappropriate and things they didn't want to do. That was the people who were low in self-control, the people who weren't that successful at achieving their goals in life. In other words, this is not a case of people who have cake in the refrigerator and are very good at resisting, opening the refrigerator to eat the cake. These are just people who don't have cake in the refrigerator and are very good at resisting opening the refrigerator to eat the cake these are just people who don't have cake in the refrigerator exactly or if they do they don't see it
they have coded that as okay that's my kids cake I don't eat that I eat the fruit and I like the fruit how do they do it? it turns out that when you build a habit it's like putting on a set of unconscious mental blinders. Once in place, the blinders protect you from temptations and distractions. The more you ignore those temptations, the stronger the blinders become. To put this another way, habits are self-reinforcing. They can be difficult to start, but once in place, they have a life of their own,
because they stop being conscious and become automatic and unconscious. In fact, once you have developed a habit, you will stick to it, even if the alternative is objectively easier. Wendy has a nice example of this from her own life. She sometimes goes biking with a friend who's a professional cyclist. Yeah, so she and I were good friends and we'd love to talk about our families and just exchange information about our lives.
And that would happen as we started the bike ride. Now she's a professional cyclist, so you might wonder what she's doing riding with me. Well, I rode with her on her days off when she was supposed to be just not breaking a sweat. And that was fine, you know, because that's the speed I ride at. And so we'd have a good time talking and chatting, and then after we'd been cycling for maybe an hour and a half, she would start speeding up. And she did this consistently. I'm like, try not to take it personally, because you know, you can't talk to somebody who's cycling that fast. And I asked her at the end of one of our rides, so what happens at the end?
Because you know, I kind of lose you. And she said, well, I'm just so tired at going at the slow pace. I can't control my actions anymore and I just naturally speed up. So what this indicates, I think it's a fascinating example because it indicates that the habit is not necessarily the easiest thing or the low effort thing to do. Instead, it's what you usually do that you fall back on. There have been anecdotal accounts of how long it takes to develop a habit, and you and others have had the insight that this number is probably not the same for different kinds
of habits, that some habits in some ways are easier to form than others. Perhaps they have larger rewards than others. What does the science tell us about how long it takes to develop different habits like exercising or writing or going to the gym? Habits are cognitive associations, they're mental associations that we form when we repeat an action over and over again in a given context and then get a reward. When you do that, you are learning very slowly and incrementally to associate that context with that behavior. So the next time you're in that context, the behavior automatically comes to mind. You might be very consistent in
how you repeat an action and I might be more variable and if I'm more variable it's going to take longer to form that habit, that mental association in mind, but also for complex behaviors. For things that have many different parts it takes longer to form a habit. And the best evidence we have at this point is from a study that had people add a simple health behavior to their day, adding something like a glass of water took two months to become automated so that you don't have to make decisions about it. Something like going to the gym could take three, four months before,
of going every day, before it becomes really habitual in the sense that you don't have to think. You just do. So one implication of this is that just as you can have good habits that cause you to do things unthinkingly, you can also develop bad habits that cause you to do things unthinkingly. You mentioned another neighbor friend of yours who sometimes has to decide whether to drive to her kid's school or walk to her kid's school, and that revealed something really interesting about the power of habit. Yeah, so we lived in a small neighborhood and the school was actually right next to her house. One night at a parent-teacher conference, I watched her get into her car and drive to
the school parking lot, which was actually further from the front door of the school than her house. Her habit was to get in the car, and this was in Texas, so it was hot. So if she'd been thinking, she would have been very cognizant of the weather and that she was actually gonna be uncomfortable for longer if she took her car than if she walked. There's an underlying subtext to many of these stories and
that subtext is that in much of our lives our actions are actually not being driven by conscious and deliberate intention and that's a subtext that runs through much of your book. This idea that much of our lives actually is being run on autopilot. Yes, one of the first studies we did, we tried to figure out what percentage of daily actions are habitual in the way that you describe. And what we found is that about 43% of everyday actions are done repeatedly, almost every day in the same context. Again, it's very much like driving. We have this general sense that we're doing things, but it's not driven by an active decision-making process. So the interesting thing is that because we don't acknowledge or often recognize how powerful
these unthinking forces are, In many of our campaigns, our public health campaigns, for example, we focus primarily on changing people's conscious beliefs and attitudes. And you have some really interesting ideas on how this plays out when it comes to getting people to eat right. You've looked at, for example, campaigns to get people to eat more fruits and vegetables. What do you find? Yeah, probably one of the most famous campaigns actually started here in California, 5 a day, eating 5 a day fruits and vegetables. 5 a day, 5 a day, we all know that is the healthy one. Fruits and vegetables, and they're okay, are healthy with these 5 a day. When it began in the 1990s, only 8% of the U.S. population realized that they needed to
eat five servings of fruits and vegetables a day. Five years later, it over a third of Americans understood they need deep five servings of fruits and vegetables a day. But when you look at what people were doing, the campaign looks really different. So before the campaign started, 11% of us were actually eating five servings of fruits and vegetables a day. 10 years later, still 11 percent. And even more recent assessments have shown that Americans are declining from that point. Fewer and fewer of us are eating that amount.
And part of the reason for this is much of our eating is habitual. We do it automatically, we shop automatically, we only go down certain aisles in the grocery store, people might not even go down the produce aisle. So they're not going to be influenced by this abstract thought, yes, fruits and vegetables are good for me. Instead, they're eating based on the environment that they're in, and the patterns they've developed. I mean, I feel like I see this in so many different campaigns where the idea is if we can
change people's beliefs, their behavior will follow. And of course, intuitively, that's a very appealing idea, but really, the evidence doesn't seem to support it? No, I mean, it does support it for one-off behaviors, limited behaviors, single-time behavior change. So if you're trying to get people to sign up for a program, for example, then convincing people to do it and giving them the opportunity right when you convince them is probably a pretty effective way to do it. But so many of health behaviors, of financial behaviors, relationships, productivity, these things involve long-term change in behavior. And that you don't get by convincing people to do things.
So if conscious beliefs and intentions don't get people to do things. So if conscious beliefs and intentions don't get people to change their behavior, how can we use science to start habits or break them? That's when we come back. Stay with us. Wendy Wood is a professor of psychology and business at the University of Southern California. She says corporations are increasingly drawing on insights about habits to influence their workforce. One example, Uber. Being a driver on Uber is difficult in many ways, right?
You're taking your own personal car and you are using it for business. You have a bunch of strangers sitting in the back. So Uber would put a lot of money into training and evaluating drivers and their cars, and then drivers would quit after, before they got to 10 rides. And so Uber would lose money. So what they decided to do was they decided to automate,
and you've probably heard this, when you're in an Uber, at the end of your ride, the phone app pings, and then assigns the driver to the next ride. So they don't have time to think, and maybe decide, okay, this is getting difficult time going home. They're off on their next ride. And so it moves them forward through the process to the point where they start feeling more comfortable with what they're
doing. And they can develop some habitual patterns of dealing with customers. So there's an important insight here, and this is an insight that's useful, not just for a multi-billion dollar business trying to manipulate the behavior of its workforce, but it's an insight that affects all of us. When I'm sitting on my couch and I'm watching Netflix, at the end of each episode of Netflix,
I don't actually have to press any buttons. Netflix tells me in nine seconds, the next episode is going to start. And that's really the same idea as what Uber is doing towards drivers. It's basically saying, you can change people's behavior by essentially making it frictionless for them to keep doing the behavior.
Yes. Yeah. And that is essentially what most commercial industries have figured out how to do at this point in one way or another. Will you have fries with that? Is probably the classic example of encouraging certain behaviors, making behaviors easy, consumption, spending money. You can think of so many examples of this in our modern culture. I wonder if we can take this insight Wendy and apply it to how you can actually start to build habits. So in exactly the same way that corporations in some ways manipulate us into doing what they want us to do. I want to explore how we might be able to
manipulate ourselves into doing things that we think are good for us. Yeah, so we all know that people are most likely to repeat actions that are easy for them and actions that are fun. that are easy for them and actions that are fun. So if you really don't like going to the gym, then you're not going to do it very often. And you need to figure out something to do to make it more fun. Making it easy is also critical. So there was a study that is quite amazing, I think, but it has been replicated a couple of times on how far people travel to the gym. If people travel
about three and a half miles, then they are likely to go to the gym five times a month on average. If people travel five miles, then they're likely to go only once a month on average. Wow. The five miles presents friction. The 3.5 miles is much less friction and makes the behavior more likely. We just don't have to struggle so much to get there and anything that reduces the struggle and the stress is going to make habits more likely to form.
I don't know if you noticed this, but Wendy and I have mentioned a specific word a couple of times in the last few minutes. Friction. When things are difficult to do, they have high friction. When doing something is effortless, there's low friction. It turns out this word is incredibly important to understand how habits work. One unusual study revealed the power of friction using stale popcorn. We did it in a local movie theater. We had the movie patrons watch a bunch of trailers and rate them for us.
This summer, experience the life in the world's greatest athlete. Every day, millions of people go through the same routine while life passes them by. Coming soon, personal. And supposedly as compensation, we gave them boxes of popcorn to eat. Now unbeknownst to them, some got stale popcorn, which we had popped earlier and kept in our lab for a week in a plastic bag. So it was pretty bad. And others got boxes of fresh popcorn. And what we found
was this, that people who don't eat popcorn regularly in the movie theater did just what you'd expect. They ate a lot of the fresh popcorn, the stale popcorn they just avoided. What was most interesting though, are the people, the movie patrons, who often ate popcorn in the movie theater. They ate 70% of these boxes, whether they were fresh or stale. Now what's so surprising is, we asked them afterwards how much they liked the popcorn,
and they could all tell us they hated the stale popcorn. But to people who have habits, the cues are so strong in that particular context that they just respond to them without thinking and they get the stale popcorn in their mouth and they think, oh, that wasn't great. But then before they know it, they're back to eating again. That same stuff that they don't like. Wendy added an interesting twist to the study,
and this is the part where friction comes in. She ran the same experiment, except this time, she got right-handed volunteers to eat the popcorn with their left hand and left-handed volunteers to eat with their right hand. And that's not something that most of us do on a regular basis. So it made the eating more thoughtful.
If you add that thought to the behavior, you make people attend to it, then they quit, then our strong habit participants quit eating the stale popcorn. It's as if if they had to think about it, they realized, oh, this stuff really tastes bad. And so I'm not going to eat it anymore. So in some ways, if I could put this another way, is one of the insights of your work that if you want to build something into a habit, you actually want to try and make it as unconscious and as automatic as possible. And if you want to interrupt a bad habit, you might want to find ways to try and make it just a little bit more conscious, trying to
be a little bit more mindful of the habit as you're actually performing it. Is that an insight that would come away from your work? Yes, yes, I think that's true. And we see people all around us who do those things or don't, right? So people who are very successful as writers, as athletes, they are people who have made the repetition automatic, and they do it every day. You know, you hear about famous writers turning out certain
numbers of pages a day, writing for certain, a certain amount of time, athletes work out for certain periods every day. These people have automated the hard work. Doesn't make it, doesn't mean that they're not working hard, but they've made it easier for themselves to do that. If you want to make it more difficult to do something, you want to stop yourself, then you figure out ways to add friction to the behaviors that you don't want to engage in. That makes you stop and think, and perhaps gives you a bit of a chance to realize, oh, this is not really what I intended, maybe I can do something better. You were at a conference in Europe one time and you used the power of friction to get people
to eat more fruit. What did you do Wendy? Oh, well, this was actually a conference that I run on Habits on Catalina Island here in California, but we had that year a bunch of European participants. And I've noticed that European Z lots of food. So I ordered extra food for them. But the cafeteria folks had put the fruit in a box that was just to the side of the cafeteria line
and no one was eating it. And I noticed it, so I put it right in the middle of the line and it went immediately. By then the bananas were a little brownish, but they still, it was obvious and people, I had made it easy and obvious how to get the fruit, people ate it. In many ways, this is the same insight of the irresistible staircase in Seattle. The architects hid the elevators out of sight, by placing the stairs front and center, by making their use frictionless, the building made it more likely people would unconsciously choose the path of least resistance and climb the stairs. When we come back, how to build our own versions of the irresistible staircase? We look at more ways that we can use friction and other tools to change our habits.
Stay with us. There is a reason many of us form bad habits. Things like smoking or gambling have long-term negative consequences, but they're extremely rewarding in the short term. Wendy says habits are powerfully shaped by short-term rewards. This has to do with the reward component of habits. So what we know about rewards is that our brain responds with dopamine when we get rewarded. And that dopamine is what helps to build the mental associations of habit in our brain. And this means that only certain types of rewards are really going to be useful in forming habits, and they're the rewards you experience immediately.
Things like exercising or eating healthy food often have tremendous long-term benefits, but they're often not very fun to do. No surprise, they don't produce the quick dopamine verse. So how do you form habits around healthy behaviors? You have to consciously figure out ways to link these healthy behaviors with short-term rewards. Don't just force yourself to eat more veggies, figure out ways to make the veggies delicious and enjoyable. So if when you eat vegetables, if you really like the taste of beautifully cooked vegetables, and you feel pride in eating healthfully and taking care of yourself, those are immediate
诸如锻炼身体或吃健康食品之类的活动通常有巨大的长期益处，但它们通常不是很有趣。毫无疑问，它们不会产生快速的多巴胺刺激。那么，你如何围绕健康行为养成习惯呢？你必须有意识地找出将这些健康行为与短期奖励联系起来的方法。不要强迫自己多吃蔬菜，要想办法让蔬菜变得美味可口。因此，当你吃蔬菜时，如果你真的很喜欢烹饪精美的蔬菜的味道，并且为健康饮食和照顾自己感到自豪，这些都是即时的
rewards, and they will help you build a habit. If your reward is some bonus at the end of the week or something that you give yourself for achieving, say, some health goal several months down the road. That's not going to be the kind of reward that builds a habit because it's not there when you are acting. So, there's an interesting implication of this, and in some ways it's a sad implication, which is when you think about it, this explains why it's easy to form a habit of eating dessert or smoking or drinking, because the rewards when you do those things are relatively quick,
奖励，它们将帮助你养成习惯。如果你的奖励是周末的某种额外奖励，或者是你在几个月后实现某个健康目标时给予自己的某种东西。那将不会成为那种能够养成习惯的奖励，因为它在你行动时并不存在。因此，这里有一个有趣的含义，在某种程度上这是一个悲伤的含义，也就是说，仔细想想，这解释了为什么养成吃甜点、抽烟或喝酒的习惯很容易，因为当你做这些事情时，奖励相对较快，
and exercise routine or a healthy diet. These are not things where you see the benefit for very long periods of time, unless as you say, you develop these intrinsic systems to feel pride as you're doing something, not just waiting for the reward three months or three years down the line. That's exactly right. But you have a little bit more control than that, because you can add things to behaviors that might not be intrinsically rewarding to you initially. As I said, you can listen to good music when you work out. I hate to admit this.
而锻炼日常或健康的饮食。除非像你所说的那样，你在做事时培养了内在系统来感到自豪，而不是仅仅等待三个月或三年后的奖励，否则这些并不是你在很长一段时间内能看到好处的事情。完全正确。但你拥有比这更多的控制权，因为你可以向最初可能对你没有内在奖励的行为中添加一些东西。正如我所说，你可以在锻炼时听好音乐。我很不想承认这一点。
I work out on elliptical some days and that's probably the most boring thing you can do in the world. So I only, and I watch competitive cooking shows when I do it. And I only let myself watch those shows when I'm on the elliptical. So that's my reward for working out. And it's made it into quite a pleasurable habit, actually. Tell me about your own efforts to become a regular, a habitual jogger. How did that work?
我有时在椭圆机上锻炼，这可能是世界上最无聊的事情。所以我只，而且我边锻炼边看烹饪竞技节目。我只允许自己在这个时候看这些节目。这就是我锻炼的奖励。事实上，这已经变成了一个非常愉快的习惯。跟我聊聊你自己成为一名常规慢跑者的努力。那是怎么做到的？
What were the obstacles you faced? And how did you try and device methods to overcome them? Oh, this is when my sons were young. I have two sons, two years apart in age, and I had a full-time job, and a husband I had a full-time job and a husband who had a full-time job. So that was a bit of a challenge to find any time to exercise or do anything else. And that was a real challenge for me early on.
你遇到了什么障碍？你是如何尝试设计方法来克服它们的？哦，这是在我儿子们还小的时候。我有两个儿子，年龄相差两岁，我有一份全职工作，还有一个有一份全职工作并且也有全职工作的丈夫。所以要找到时间锻炼或做其他事情确实是一个挑战。这对我早期来说是一个真正的挑战。
For about five years I struggled trying to figure that out. If you have little kids, you know, you say, I'm going to work out today at four o'clock and then one of them gets sick or another has a friend who comes over and you can't leave or leave them. Something always comes up and then with your job on top of it, it was just impossible. Every night I'd go back and I'd go to bed and I'd be like, okay, another failure. Until I decided that I was going to have to find a time when I could do it regularly, consistently, and that was early in the morning.
在大约五年的时间里，我一直在努力弄清楚这一点。如果你有小孩子，你知道的，你会说，我今天四点钟要锻炼，然后其中一个生病了或者另一个有朋友过来，你就不能离开或者把他们留下。总会有事情发生，再加上你的工作，这简直是不可能的。每天晚上我回去睡觉时都会想，好吧，又失败了。直到我决定必须找一个能够规律、持续地进行锻炼的时间，那就是清晨。
So I started running, I was a committed runner for many years, I started running at six in the morning, and that was very hard to start off with because for me that didn't come naturally and I really dreaded that. But it got easier each time and I actually did listen to the radio and I found that to be a great sort of way to wake up ultimately. One of the things I did to help was, I'm telling you all of my secrets here, I actually slept in my running clothes because it made it easier to then get up and just get out the door early in the morning. And then if I got back by seven o'clock, then I could make my boys breakfast and see them off to school and go live the rest of my day without having this
所以我开始跑步，我多年来一直是一个坚定的跑步者，我早上六点开始跑步，一开始非常难，因为对我来说那不是自然而然的，我真的很害怕。但每次都变得容易了，我实际上听了收音机，并发现这最终是一种很好的唤醒方式。我为了帮忙所做的事情之一是——我在这里把我的所有秘密都告诉你们——我实际上穿着跑步服睡觉，因为这更容易让我早起并早早出门。然后如果我在七点钟前回来的话，我就可以给我的儿子们做早餐，送他们去上学，然后去过我一天的其余生活，而不用担心
worry about how I was going to get exercise in given the rest of my schedule. So it worked. So what I find so interesting about that is that our conscious minds in some ways can help, but they help primarily not so much in terms of exercising willpower, but in scheming our ways to make the habit as frictionless as possible. And so in some ways, your conscious mind came up with this idea to say, let me sleep in my jogging clothes. So when the alarm goes off at 6 o'clock,
考虑到我的其他日程安排，我将如何进行锻炼。所以它成功了。所以我觉得最有趣的是，我们的意识在某些方面可以提供帮助，但它们的主要帮助不在于行使意志力，而在于策划各种方法，使习惯尽可能地减少摩擦。所以从某种程度上说，你的意识想出了这个主意，说，让我穿着慢跑服睡觉。因此，当闹钟在6点钟响起时，
I don't have the thought in my head, oh no, I have to spend time changing before I go out, you've just made it a little more frictionless, a little more easy. Exactly. It's sort of like what professional chefs do. So I went up to the Culinary Institute of America and took a few of their preliminary classes, how they trained chefs in something called miso-ploss, which is how to set up your environment to make it easy to create great dishes, consistently great dishes
我脑子里没有这样的想法：哦不，我出门前还得花时间换衣服，你只是让事情变得不那么费力，更容易一些。完全正确。这有点像专业厨师的做法。所以我去了美国烹饪学院上了几节初级课程，学习他们如何在一种叫做“备料（miso-ploss）”的东西中训练厨师，也就是如何布置你的环境，以便轻松地持续创造出美味的菜肴，每次都能做出一直很棒的菜肴
each time. And they described to me the dilemma of beginning chefs, is they wanted to just jump in and do it. You know? Let's just do it. And they would get some flour, some sugar, some of the components together and they'd try to start creating stuff. But then they'd figure out, oh no, I really need more flour and I wasn't supposed to put all the sugar in here and I was supposed to do something else there. And so they have to learn, this is when they learn mise en place, putting everything in place before they actually begin. And they put it in place in order.
他们向我描述了初学者厨师的困境，他们只想直接上手做。你知道的？让我们直接开始吧。他们会把一些面粉、一些糖、一些配料凑在一起，然后试图开始制作东西。但随后他们会发现，哦不，我其实需要更多的面粉，我不应该把所有的糖都放进来，我本该在别的地方做点别的。所以他们必须学习，这就是他们学习备料（mise en place）的时候，在真正开始之前把一切都准备就绪。而且他们按顺序把一切摆放好。
So they're not thinking a lot, they're not making decisions while they're actually cooking. Instead, they are cute by all of the implements and the food and the prepared items in front of them on what goes next, and it makes it much easier for them to be consistent and actually produce the same thing. And I was impressed with that as a metaphor for behavior change, because if you structure the environment ahead of time, yes it's work, yes it does take executive control, our conscious thinking selves, but then we make it so much easier for us to sort of automate all of the other decisions, so that in their case they can think about ways to make it their current cakes even more
这样他们就不用想太多，在实际烹饪时也不用做决定。相反，他们面前的各种器具、食物和预处理物品会提示他们接下来该做什么，这使他们更容易保持一致并实际产出相同的东西。我对这一点印象深刻，认为它是行为改变的一个隐喻，因为如果你提前规划环境，是的，这需要工作，是的，这确实需要执行控制、我们有意识思考的自我，但随后我们让我们更容易将会话中的其他所有决定自动化，以便在他们的情况下，他们可以考虑如何使他们当前的蛋糕更加
wonderful and pastries even tastier as they put them together. They can put the flourish into them because they have automated the basic components. Wendy says you can also use friction in the opposite direction to disrupt a habit. Think about campaigns to limit smoking. By the time the Surgeon General's report came out on the dangers of smoking, people had a pretty good idea. It convinced people that they needed to stop smoking.
精彩，糕点在组合时更加美味。他们可以为它们增添光彩，因为他们已经将基本组成部分自动化了。温迪说，你也可以利用相反方向的摩擦来打破一个习惯。想想限制吸烟的运动。当美国外科医生的关于吸烟危害的报告出来时，人们对此有了相当清楚的认识。它说服了人们，让他们知道自己需要戒烟。
But in fact, sales of cigarettes in the US continued to increase into the 70s. So people were convinced. They knew it was not good for them, but they kept doing it. It was only once we started modifying the environment. So warning labels on cigarette packs. We removed vending machines, I don't know if you remember, cigarette vending machines, but you can't find them anymore, because there are now rules about how you can purchase cigarettes. Sigarettes are typically put behind the counter, and you have to ask for them in order to purchase them. We set bands on smoking in public places so that you can't easily anymore just light up in your office, in a restaurant, on a plane.
但事实上，美国香烟的销量在70年代仍在继续增长。所以人们已经确信了。他们知道这对他们没有好处，但他们还是继续抽。直到我们开始改变环境。例如香烟盒上的警告标签。我们取消了自动售货机，我不知道你们是否还记得香烟自动售货机，但你再也找不到它们了，因为现在有了关于如何购买香烟的规定。香烟通常被放在柜台后面，你必须要求购买才能买到。我们在公共场所设立了禁烟令，这样你就不能再轻易地在办公室、餐馆、飞机上点烟了。
And then we started taxing. We started taxing cigarettes. All of that took huge political decision making and commitment to make it happen. But isn't it fascinating, Wendy, that telling people that smoking is going to give them emphysema and lung cancer, that these things in some ways are less effective than telling them they have to walk a hundred yards, get up from that desk, walk outside the building, and light up outside. You would think that the first would actually have much more effect than the second, but that does not turn out to be the case. You're right. We're pitiful.
然后我们开始征税。我们开始对香烟征税。所有这一切都需要巨大的政治决策和承诺才能实现。但是温迪，告诉人们吸烟会导致肺气肿和肺癌，在某种程度上这些东西不如告诉他们必须步行一百码、从办公桌旁站起来、走出大楼并在外面点烟来得有效，这难道不是很迷人吗？你可能会认为前者实际上比后者产生更大的影响，但事实并非如此。你说得对。我们真可怜。
We would like to think that we are rational and respond to the data on cancer and emphysema. But the reality is we tend to act on autopilot on what we are doing already because it's so much easier. It's very hard to exert that kind of control. So in a way what the government was doing is it was making it easier for us to do the thing that we already wanted to do, which is to smoke glass. We've talked about how you can decrease friction to build good habits and increase friction to dismantle bad habits. We looked at how you can make healthy behaviors automatic and mindless and make unhealthy behaviors conscious and effortful. Here are three additional ideas that build on these insights. The first is something that Wendy
我们愿意认为自己是理性的，并对关于癌症和肺气肿的数据做出反应。但现实是，我们倾向于在已经在做的事情上靠自动驾驶行事，因为那样要容易得多。要施加那种控制是非常困难的。所以在某种程度上，政府在做的事是让我们更容易做我们本来就想做的事情，那就是抽烟。我们已经讨论了如何通过减少摩擦来建立好习惯，通过增加摩擦来消除坏习惯。我们探讨了如何使健康行为变得自动化和无意识，并使不健康行为变得有意识和费力。这里有三个基于这些洞察的额外想法。第一个是温迪
calls piggybacking or stacking. It is taking a behavior that you're already doing and inserting a new behavior that you want to add. So you want to remember to take your meds. Maybe you have meds prescribed by your doctor that you're supposed to take every night. If you want to remember to take them, a good way to do it is to put it on your nightstand and then whatever you do last before you get into bed is it. Turn off your phone, set your alarm, whatever it is, just insert taking that pill in that stream of behavior, and over time it will become automated,
称之为搭便车或叠加的东西。它是指采用你已经在做的一项行为，并插入你想添加的新行为。所以你想记住吃药。也许你的医生给你开了药，要求你每天晚上服用。如果你想记住吃药，一个好方法是把它放在床头柜上，然后你在上床睡觉前做的最后一件事就是这个。关掉手机，定好闹钟，无论是什么，只需把吃药这个动作插入到那个行为流中，随着时间的推移它就会变成自动化的，
much like the automated pattern that you're already performing. In other words, you can essentially string habits together like a chain. Yes, yeah. It's a sort of a short cut to forming a new habit. Use one that you already have. Another powerful insight has to do with the role of what Wendy calls cues, things that prompt you to do something. Wendy mentioned cues in the context of the popcorn study. If you've ever been a smoker, you might have noticed there are certain triggers to your smoking. Maybe you come home at the end of the day and you light up on your front porch.
很像你已经在执行的自动化模式。换句话说，你本质上可以像链条一样把习惯串联起来。是的，是的。这是一种形成新习惯的捷径。利用你已经拥有的习惯。另一个强有力的见解与温迪所谓的线索（能够促使你做某事的事物）的作用有关。温迪在爆米花研究的背景下提到了线索。如果你曾经是个烟民，你可能已经注意到吸烟有某些触发因素。也许你一天结束回家，在你的前廊点上一支烟。
The porch is what Wendy calls a cue. Cues are very powerful in creating new habits or preserving old ones. Wendy uses cues in her own life to build new habits. One cue for her is to wake up and have breakfast with her husband. That's her signal, her cue, that the next thing she needs to do is sit down at her computer and write for two hours. If I give myself a couple of hours in the morning to write if I structure it into my schedule, then I take away all of the decision-making and the stress about when and where I'm gonna do it. I don't mean to say that it makes writing easy. Writing is always a challenge for everyone, but it does make the
门廊就是温迪所说的线索。线索在建立新习惯或保持旧习惯方面非常强大。温迪在自己的生活中利用线索来建立新习惯。对她来说的一个线索是醒来和丈夫一起吃早餐。那是她的信号，她的线索，表明她需要做的下一件事是坐在电脑前写两个小时的文章。如果我给自己留出早上的几个小时来写作，如果我把它编排进我的日程表中，那么我就消除了关于何时何地完成它的所有决策和压力。我并不是说这会让写作变得容易。写作对每个人来说都是一个挑战，但它确实使
process easier, so I'm not all the time struggling about whether I should be doing this or something else. That's being decided. This is part of my job and I just need to do it. There's one last source of new habits and it comes from an unexpected place. Chaos. When our lives go haywire, the cues that normally surround us disappear. Wendy says this can be a profound opportunity for reinvention. There's actually been a lot of research on something called habit discontinuity, the jargony term, but it is studies of people when they're undergoing change. And what we've learned is that that's an opportunity for people to try out new things
过程变得更容易，所以我不会一直在纠结我是应该做这个还是别的什么。这已经决定了。这是我的工作，我只需要去做。还有一个最后的新习惯来源，它来自一个意想不到的地方。混乱。当我们的生活陷入混乱时，通常围绕着我们的线索就会消失。温迪说，这可能是一个深刻的重塑机会。事实上，关于一种叫做习惯中断（一个术语）的东西已经有很多研究，但它是对处于变化中的人们的研究。我们了解到的是，这是人们尝试新事物的机会，
that they didn't have the chance to do at, say, an old job or an old place where they lived. There's many such life disruptions, right? Relationships and you get a family, life gets disrupted. And the typical way we think about that is that that's stressful. And that that's not a good time for making new decisions. But in fact, it actually turns out to be an opportunity for them to act more authentically on their values. So because they're making those decisions, they have to think, do I want to do this?
这些事是他们在旧工作或旧住所时没有机会做的。有许多这样的人生变故，对吧？人际关系以及你有了家庭，生活被打乱了。而我们对此的典型看法是，那是充满压力的。那不是做出新决策的好时机。但事实上，这最终成为了他们根据自己的价值观做出更真实行动的机会。因此，由于他们在做这些决定，他们必须思考，我想要这样做吗？
How do I do this? What are my new choices here? It's an opportunity to rethink some of the practical decisions you've made in your life and maybe to act more in ways that are consistent with how you want to be. act more in ways that are consistent with how you want to be. Wendy Wood is a professor of psychology and business at the University of Southern California. She's the author of Good Habits, Bad Habits, the science of making positive changes that stick. Wendy, thank you for joining me today on Hidden Brain.
我该怎么做？我在这里的新选择是什么？这是一个重新思考你在生活中做出的实际决策的机会，也许可以以更符合你期望成为的方式行动。以更符合你期望成为的方式行动。温迪·伍德是南加州大学的心理学和商业教授。她是《好习惯，坏习惯：建立持久积极改变的科学》一书的作者。温迪，非常感谢你今天来到《隐藏的大脑》。
It was lovely to talk to you, thank you. This episode was produced by Thomas Liu and Angus Chen. It was edited by Tara Boyle and Raina Cohen. Our team includes Paath Shah, Laura Quarell and Jenny Schmidt. For me one of the key takeaways from the episode is how we can become better at building and maintaining habits. Many of you already have built a habit of listening to our show every week. Here's a new one you should start, or an old one you could strengthen. Donate to your local public radio station. Go to donate.npr.org slash hidden brain.
很高兴与你交谈，谢谢。本集由托马斯·刘和安格斯·陈制作。由塔拉·博伊尔和雷娜·科恩剪辑。我们的团队包括帕思·沙阿、劳拉·夸雷尔和珍妮·施密特。对我和许多人来说，本集的主要收获之一是我们如何能更好地建立和维持习惯。你们中的许多人已经养成了每周收听我们的节目的习惯。这里有一个你应该开始的新习惯，或者一个你可以强化的旧习惯。向你当地的公共广播电台捐款。请访问 donate.npr.org slash hidden brain。
Again, that's donate.npr.org slash hidden brain. A ronsang heroes this week are Noah Carnahan and Rob Harris. Noah and Rob are part of our digital media team. They make sure our audio sounds good on all the different platforms it's heard on, from podcasting apps to the NPR website. A while back we had some problems translating the audio we were hearing in our headphones into the right format for all these different platforms. Noah and Rob worked with us into the Wii hours, always maintaining their common composure as we
再次提醒，网址是 donate.npr.org slash hidden brain。本周的无名英雄是诺亚·卡纳汉和罗布·哈里斯。诺亚和罗布是我们数字媒体团队的成员。他们确保我们的音频在听到它的所有不同平台上听起来都很好，从播客应用程序到NPR网站。不久前，我们在将耳机中听到的音频转换为适合所有这些不同平台的正确格式时遇到了一些问题。诺亚和罗布与我们一起工作到深夜，当我们
played detective, trying to get to the heart of the problem. Also, thank you for listening to Hidden Brain over the course of the past year. If you liked this episode, please share it with someone who doesn't know much about podcasting. If they need help, please show them how to subscribe to our show. I'm Shankar Vedantam. Happy New Year. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
像侦探一样试图找到问题的核心时，他们始终保持着冷静和镇定。另外，感谢你在过去一年里收听《隐藏的大脑》。如果你喜欢这一集，请把它分享给对播客不太了解的人。如果他们需要帮助，请向他们展示如何订阅我们的节目。我是尚卡尔·韦达姆。新年快乐。本集目前还没有评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。